when we discussed the rolling of the
wheel we chose a reference frame fixed
to the ground so that was our what we
called frame a and in that reference
frame the motion of the point p on the
rim was quite complicated now what we'd
like to look at it in the reference
frame moving with the centre of mass
and we call that frame CM now the
picture there is much easier because the
object is in that reference frame the
center of mass is not moving and the
point P on the rim the object is just
undergoing circular motion so in that
frame the velocity of that point P in
the center-of-mass frame is just tangent
to the circle and as the object moves
around at a later time the velocity is
always tangential and in this reference
frame it's just pure circular motion and
we know that the speed in that reference
frame is given by the radius of the
wheel times the rate d theta/dt and here
let's define the variable theta this way
and so in this frame what's happening is
pure circular motion now we know our law
of addition of velocity tells us that
the velocity in the frame fixed to the
ground of that point is equal to the
velocity of the center of mass plus the
velocity of the object the point on the
rim in the center-of-mass frame now what
we want to do now is draw a picture
which illustrates this law of addition
of velocities